on va l'intubé pour procéder après à la
trachéo sur le front covid les malades
sont moins nombreux mais les décisions
restent déchirantes comme cet homme dans
la jeune cinquantaine foudroyés par le
virus
on pourrait devoir vous intuber et vous
plonger dans le coma lui annonce le
docteur Patrick Bellemare
comme la quasi-totalité des patients
soignés pour la covid à l'hôpital
sacré-cœur au moment où on se parle il y
en a quatre dans notre clientèle puis
c'était 4 non vacciné il y a moins de
cas que l'hiver dernier mais leur nombre
augmente lentement on compte 110
hospitalisations 8 de plus que lundi 33
patients sont aux soins intensifs une
augmentation de 4 par rapport à la
veille mais vu le manque de personnel
cette petite hausse a déjà des
conséquences les deux chirurgies majeurs
annulés pour cette avant midi
c'est les deux patients covid que j'ai
dû monter en fin de nuit des chirurgies
doivent déjà être repoussés
à jeun à 6h du matin mais en début
d'après-midi on lui annonce que sa
chirurgie vasculaire est annulée ce
doublement de
parce que jusqu'à maintenant j'imagine
qu'il y avait un corps spécial plus
urgent que le mien qui a fait que j'ai
pas pu passer le premier
d'ailleurs j'apprends à cause de la
commune les installations sont prêtes
pour affronter une quatrième vague mais
le personnel est plus rare et plus
fatigué que l'an dernier
c'est des soignants puis on peut pas
improviser des soignants experts en
soins critiques du jour au lendemain ça
fonctionne pas comme ça l'exaspération
ici est palpable et les arguments des
opposants au vaccin sont mal reçus
ayez une discussion avec vos proches sur
qu'est-ce que vous voulez comme soin si
jamais ça tourne mal tu sais c'est quoi
votre niveau de soin là voulez-vous
qu'on fasse tout ou qu'on vous intime
qu'on vous prend sur une machine vous
voulez qu'on vous laisse aller là pour
rester conséquent avec votre choix le
type d'argumentaire qu'on entend
actuellement c'est un choix individuel
puis au nom des libertés individuelles
j'ai pas assumé la vaccination
au nom des libertés individuelles je
roule pas à l'envers